i didn't have to um
like go through the whole auditioning
process and then i found out i got the
part i was really excited too because i
love the script
but yeah it's really hard because most
this time we'd be staring at a piece of
tape so
otherwise it'd be like um like one of
those
these things oh sorry
adventures beware
my favorite scene the monkey scene
when my brother and i peeked in the
kitchen we saw the monkeys trashing our
kitchen those probably were my favorite
when they were looking at that little tv
watching the wizard of oz and then they
started to dance around like the monkeys
that was my favorite part that was so
cute
i think it's gonna press everyone
because well especially with robin's
movies i mean every movie he does is
classy
and everyone loves so i think this is
one
that everyone will love too and he's one
of the funniest guys
and he he like he's such a nice and
genuine man he would improvise sometimes
but you know you just have to keep going
you know with him he's really funny
it's hard to keep a straight face and
it's really funny especially like
when you're watching the movie and
everything and you can't really laugh at
their jokes so i would just kind of zone
them out when bonnie and robin were just
were just like joking because otherwise
you'd be like laughing rolling on the
floor
we can't get through the glass we're
safe
either one of you know how to drive and
he did
um ethel merman and he'd sing all these
quiet songs
really really loud he'd go like let me
tell you a secret
let me whisper in your ear and you'd be
like screaming it was really funny
we did a lot of our own stunts and robin
did all the wrestling with the crocodile
and everything
actually it was really weird because i'd
be swimming around and suddenly you just
feel like a foot against yours and i
would like scream and then i'd see like
this big head in my eye and everything
it was really scary
robbery boots you know it's still
you know it really smells bad it was
really tough shooting the wave tank
stuff because that took two weeks for
like a minute
and we'd be in water all day long
especially my brother in the movie and i
would like have to hang from a
chandelier like through the whole scene
and so we have to stay on there but it
would really hurt on your bud because
it'd be all these wires and everything
and all this glass would be hanging down
and we'd be like oh god
plus there's a line in my aunt's bedroom
what am i supposed to do about that what
do i look like a ringling brother
they were kind of scary especially this
one i don't like this one this one
gives me the evil eye every time i see
him he like has the worst eyes
they're so scary i mean there was this
one part where
um the lion was creeping out behind this
like attic
door or whatever and then he creeps out
and you see his eyes and then he chases
down the steps and everything oh god
that's no weapon
where have you been i'm sorry dear you
have the wrong number
i love david alan greer in the movie i
loved when his car got eaten up by that
plant that was so funny
fine take it
you